The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
VICTOR COSTAN: Hi, everyone.
I am Victor.
My full name is Victor Costan.
I'm a third year Ph.D. student.
I'm in CSAIL, and
I work in systems.
I do mostly security
and distributed systems.
And I'll be your algorithm
TA for this term.
Yay.
How many people went
to lecture yesterday?
All right.
Are there any parts of the
lecture that were particularly
unclear that you
guys want to go over?
So that I schedule what I
talk about in such a way
that I'll cover that
more than the parts
that are boring and obvious.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
complexity in equations,
because I took 042
like 3 years ago.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
What else?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Maybe some
basic outlines for, like,
writing proofs relevant
to like the [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
AUDIENCE: Sort of
methodology or something.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Anything else?
OK.
We're going to get started then.
So the hardest, and I think most
important of the whole course,
is learning how to deal
with asymptotic complexity.
So asymptotic complexity
is this very nice tool
where you have a
function that looks
like this plus--
what'll I have here?
10 plus sin x.
So you have this guy, which
is quite long and horrible
and would make
your life miserable
if you'd have to
reason about it.
And you can say that this
is theta of n squared.
x, sorry.
So everything that's
here goes away.
And this constant
factor here goes away,
and it's nice and
small function.
Why is that the
case, first of all?
If I plot this function-- and
since I don't have my projector
you'll have to take
my word for it--
I will get something
that looks like this.
If I plug this
function, I will get
something that looks like this.
This is a scale from 0 to 200.
However, if I make my
scale 0 to 20,000--
Let's say 200,000 to make sure
that is going to be correct.
x squared looks like this.
And this function
looks like this.
And as you make the
scale bigger and bigger,
you can't even see
this noise anymore.
The reason is that all
the noise is in this term.
In the x to the power
of one fifth term.
And as n-- pretend this
is n, x, n same thing--
so as the input to the function
gets bigger and bigger,
this grows at a much
faster rate than this.
So if I don't care about
this, how the function grows,
I can ignore anything aside
from the dominant term.
Do people remember
this from lecture?
Does this make sense?
OK.
If it doesn't, that's great.
It means that I'm not
wasting time covering it.
So we learned about
three symbols,
or we will learn
about three symbols,
when talking about
asymptotic complexity.
The three symbols are
theta, O, and omega.
Let's say this
complicated function is g.
And this nice simple
function is f.
If I say that g of x is theta of
f of x, that means two things.
It means I have a lower
bound, like I showed here,
and the lower bound looks
something like x squared.
And it means that I also have a
higher-- an upper bound for it
that also looks like x squared.
So the upper bound would
be something like this.
And if I say this, then
I'm making a promise
that the function
stays between the lower
bound and the upper
bound, and the bounds
look sort of the same.
I can't really have x squared
here, and x squared here.
Right?
That would be impossible.
So that's why I said
they look the same.
They're not the same.
And they're not the
same, because they're
allowed to differ by
a constant factor.
So if this is f, and say
this is f prime, f of x
might be x squared.
And we know for sure that this
is going to be lower than this.
And f prime of x might
be 1.2 times x squared.
And because I have
a 1.1 here-- and I
know that these get smaller
and smaller in relation to this
as the function-- as the inputs
to the function get bigger--
I know that this is going
to be the dominating factor.
And because this is
bigger than this,
this function is
going to eventually
be larger than this function.
So I have a bound from above,
and I have a bound from below.
And the bounds look
almost the same.
They're only different
by a constant factor.
This is theta.
To make things
spicier-- by the way,
theta is really hard to
pronounce as opposed to O,
so we usually say and
write O instead of theta.
We'll talk about what O
really means in a bit.
But if you see O in a lot of
places, including our notes,
know that most of the time
we actually mean theta.
And sorry for that.
AUDIENCE: When do we
you actually mean O?
VICTOR COSTAN: You can ask
us, and we'll tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
Fortunately, it doesn't
a matter too much.
So we're trying to get an
idea of how the functions look
like in the bigger picture.
So most of the time
it doesn't matter.
I'll give you an example
though of where it matters,
and how it could matter.
So suppose I have another
function that looks like this.
So this is kind of ugly, too.
This function is g of x,
say x times 1 plus sin of x.
So I can't say anything about
the lower bound of this.
This is going to hit 0 at an
infinite number of values.
Right?
So I can't say that-- I can't
have a nice lower bound for it.
The lower bound for it is 0.
But I'm pretty sure
that it's never
going to be bigger than 2x.
Right?
And that's still
worth something.
So there's this
other function here
that's supposed to be a line.
Pretend it's a line.
f of x equals 2x.
And I know for sure
that this is never
going to exceed these, this.
And in that case, where I
only have one upper bound,
and I don't have a good lower
bound, I say that g of x
is order of f of x.
And this is where-- This
is what O really means.
It means that I only have
an upper bound and not
a lower bound.
In most of the cases when
you're coding something,
you don't really care
how well your program
can run if you're really lucky.
What you really care
about is how does it
run in the worst case?
Or how does it run
most of the time?
So suppose you're Google, and
you're writing your search
engine, and you have
to return the result
to the user in 200 milliseconds.
Because they did a study
that shows that if you return
the result in 400
milliseconds, they
lose some number of
users, which means
they lose some number
of billions a year.
So to them a guarantee that
their algorithms complete
in 200 milliseconds
is pretty important,
because it means a ton of money.
So if you have a running
time that looks like this,
that's OK, as long as
this is 200 milliseconds
for the number of pages
that Google indexes.
Does that make sense?
OK.
No answer means yes.
So if it doesn't make
sense, please say something.
OK, I will draw
another function.
Again--
AUDIENCE: Victor?
VICTOR COSTAN: --wavy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It says x times 1
plus something [INAUDIBLE].
So what?
VICTOR COSTAN: So it's--
AUDIENCE: Oh it's sin.
VICTOR COSTAN: 1 plus sin of x.
It--
AUDIENCE: It looks
like [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: Yeah.
Sorry, my handwriting
is not very good.
AUDIENCE: It's OK.
Mine isn't either.
VICTOR COSTAN: And
it doesn't really
matter what it is, it
just needs to be sin
so that it looks wavy like this.
AUDIENCE: OK.
VICTOR COSTAN: So
that I can make
something that
looks complicated.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
AUDIENCE: I have
a question, too.
In the first example, is
it 1.2 times x squared?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yes.
I wanted something
that's higher than 1.1.
AUDIENCE: It's like [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: Yes.
OK.
Now that I got a
break, does anyone else
want to ask questions?
OK.
So I'm going to draw
another function.
This one looks like this.
And this is f of x
equals 1 plus sin of x.
I have to use these signs
to make them look like that.
Times x to the power of--
What do I have there?
1 5 plus x to the
power of one fourth.
So for this function I know for
sure that it is greater than x
to the power of one fourth.
Right?
So if this is--
I know for sure that
it's greater than that.
Also if I look at this, and
I know that sin is never
bigger than 1, I know this
whole thing is going to be,
at most, 2.
So if I have another
function that
says f prime of x equals, say,
3 times x to the power of 1.5,
I know that it's going
to bound it from above.
So I have two bounds.
So it sort of looks
like this case.
Except when I use theta,
I have to make sure
that the bounds
are very similar.
They can only differ
by a constant factor.
In this case my bounds
differ by the exponent
here, which is more
than a constant factor,
so they're not the same.
So if I take my function--
which by the way is g--
if I want to say that g to the x
is theta of something, I can't.
Because no matter
what I put in here,
it's not going to be correct.
The lower bound is this,
the upper bound is this.
But what I can do is I can say
that I know for sure that it
is theta of x to the
power one fourth.
And by the way I
can also say that it
is order of x to the
power of one fifth.
So if you have weird running
times that looks like this,
then you can only
use O and omega.
And with that
being said, we will
use O for pretty much
the rest of this course.
And for most of the cases
we'll use it to mean theta.
Oh, by the way, these formulas
look ugly and complicated,
because I wanted the graphs to
look complicated to illustrate
the idea that asymptotic
notation makes
things look simpler.
In this course the running times
that you'll be dealing with
are all look like this.
They will either be order 1,
order log n, order n, order n
log n, n ordered n squared.
You might have one or two cases
where you get something else,
but most of the time if
you have something else
coming out of your occurrence,
it means you're doing it wrong.
So nice tip to have.
And you can see that I
already started doing it.
I'm already using
O instead of theta.
So I guess I'm getting
into the habit.
AUDIENCE: So why did you leave
the theta one blank for g of x?
VICTOR COSTAN:
Because whatever I
put here is going to be wrong.
If I put x to the
power of one fifth,
this is wrong, because I
can have an upper bound that
has x to the power
of one fifth in it.
But I can't have a
lower bound like that,
because this function
hits x to the power of one
fourth in infinitely
many points.
If I try to do x to the power
of one fourth, same deal.
Lower bound yes, upper bound no.
So whatever I put in here
is going to be wrong.
Thank you.
Good question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is that
1.4 or one fourth?
VICTOR COSTAN: 1.4.
They are 1.4 and 1.5
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because I thought you were
saying 1/4 and I was--
VICTOR COSTAN: Oh, sorry.
1 4, 1.4.
1.4, 1.5.
OK.
Are we good so far?
Let's go through a
couple of exercises.
So I'll give you a
few functions-- Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you make
omega-- Is that-- It's
a lower bound already without
multiplying by any constant,
or something?
Is that what it is?
VICTOR COSTAN: So
for all of these,
what you put here is the
simple, is the simple form.
So you're lower bound can
be this function multiplied
by any constant factor.
AUDIENCE: That-- So
omega means lower bound?
VICTOR COSTAN: Omega
means lower bound,
O means upper bound,
theta means both.
OK.
Any other things to clear
up before I ask questions?
So it's your turn
before it's my turn.
All right.
I'm going to go over
a few functions,
and I want you guys
to tell me what--
to help me write them
in asymptotic notation.
So I will have f of n.
And I want to know
it's theta of what?
So let's start with f of
n equals 10 to the 80.
Does anyone know
why 10 to the 80?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: That'd be O of 1.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
That's the correct answer.
You 're going ahead though.
I was wondering if-- I was
wondering if you know why?
Why did I choose this?
Does anyone know
why I chose this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is that [INAUDIBLE]?
VICTOR COSTAN: I
think that's 100.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
VICTOR COSTAN: You're
getting close though.
It's something.
AUDIENCE: It's a
really big number.
VICTOR COSTAN: It's
a really big number.
All right.
So it's a really big number.
That's the estimated number
of atoms in the universe.
So realistically any
quantity that you
deal with that will
represent the real world,
is not going to be
bigger than this.
So if you want to get
all philosophical,
you can say that for any
algorithm that you write
in any realistic
input the running time
will be theta of 1.
But if you do this, we're not
going to be happy with you
on exams.
[LAUGHTER]
So let's choose another one.
20 n to the power of 7.
What's this an
asymptotic notation?
And why?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Order O
of n to the seventh.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Of that same thing,
n to the seventh.
Thank you.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because if you
distribute the exponent 7,
20 to the seventh is a constant.
VICTOR COSTAN: Excellent.
20 to the 7 time
n to the 7, this
is a constant so it goes away.
OK.
And before I do
another one, I want
to give you guys some help
and remind you about logs.
How many people
remember the laws
of working with logs from
algebra or some math class?
All right.
You guys will be helping me
write them for everyone else.
So if I have log
of n to the 100,
and I want to get to the theta
notation for it, what is it
and why?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Excellent.
Why is that the case?
AUDIENCE: It's 100 log n.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So when I have an
exponent here, I
can pull it out in front of
the log as a constant factor.
So this is the same
thing as 100 log n.
OK.
Now if I have the logarithm to
the base using base 5 of n--
How about this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] multiply.
That's just log n?
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So this is-- can
you say that again?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So this is theta of
log n because it is--
AUDIENCE: Log n over log 5.
VICTOR COSTAN: So
that's log n over log 5.
So exponents inside the logs
turn into constant factors,
bases turn into
constant factors.
So if you have an ugly
expression inside a logarithm,
you can, most of the
time, simplify it
to something really nice.
And this contributes
to the fact that these
are the only functions that
you will see when the answer is
cleaned up in
asymptotic notation.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when
you're writing log,
are you assuming the
second base then?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yes, there
is a certain base for logs.
We're all computer scientists.
Right?
So what's the natural
base for our logarithms?
AUDIENCE: 2.
2D.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Sweet.
Math major?
AUDIENCE: No, you know I
always heard natural base--
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Yeah, it's a math joke.
So for everyone else a natural
logarithm is in base E.
For us CS people, a
natural base is 2,
because that's how many
values you have for a bit.
So log means log n is
to log base 2 of n.
The good news is
that most of the time
we're working with
asymptotic notation,
so it doesn't really matter.
We can communicate
with our math friends,
and we don't have
to talk about this.
OK.
I need to get another
complicated example.
And my memory fails me.
OK.
So log-- See, I'm using
Ln to mean the math
natural logarithm.
So we still have that
somewhere in here.
Of log n to the base 100.
They made me add all these
parentheses in the last section
to be clear, so I'm adding
them now from the start.
Who wants to help
me clean this up?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Log, log n.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
Wow, one step.
Log, log n OK.
Can you tell me
why, very quickly?
AUDIENCE: So we can simplify
out the base and the exponent
in there.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: Then--
VICTOR COSTAN: Base goes out.
Exponent goes out.
AUDIENCE: Log, log of something
is another [INAUDIBLE].
It's not exactly up there.
But can you--
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --occassionally
[INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
What does a theory student
say when they're drowning?
Log, log, log, log.
Some of you are laughing
already, because know this.
OK.
What if I want to make
this a little bit harder?
And I say log [INAUDIBLE]
5 of log n to the 100.
You have to do a
bit more work now,
you can't just use the
tricks on the right.
Anyone else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's still log, log n.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
It is still log, log n.
But for a different reason.
Right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: Almost.
OK.
Maybe not.
So the base still goes
out just like before.
But this guy now goes out here.
So I will have this be,
sort of like-- Notice
that I'm not saying
equal, I'm saying
like because I got
rid of the base.
So it's like 100 times log
n, which is log 100 plus log,
log n.
And this is a constant
factor, this grows as n grows.
So this is going to
become incredibly small
as n becomes larger and
larger, so I can get rid of it.
OK?
OK.
One more, and this one's
going to be less boring.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] out into a
separate term-- the log of 100?
Going from it in
the last step, how
are you able to cross that out?
VICTOR COSTAN: If my memory--
If my memory works, I think,
log of a b is log a plus log b.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
VICTOR COSTAN: Am I right guys?
Sweet.
Good question.
I wasn't sure, but
now that you asked,
everyone else helped me
make sure it's right.
OK.
I'm erasing so
much, because we're
going to need more
room for this.
So I have a log again, but this
time what I have inside the log
is n choose n over 2.
Does any brave soul want to come
up here and solve this for me?
No?
You guys are going to make
me write for the entire hour?
[LAUGHTER]
VICTOR COSTAN: I'll offer help.
AUDIENCE: It's n-- [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: So this is--
AUDIENCE: Is that
n factorial over --
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --n divided
by 2 factorial?
VICTOR COSTAN: n factorial
over n divided by 2 factorial,
times n divided by 2 factorial.
Close.
And I'll give up
another hint, which
is that n factorial
can be approximated
as square root of 2pi n
multiplied by n over E divided
by n to the power of n.
But I think this will
make you guys not
want to come up and solve this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: OK. [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN: I
was-- Is that it?
Is that not it?
Did I get it wrong?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] minus n.
VICTOR COSTAN: I think
that's an asymptotic.
That's what we'll-- I
think we'll get to that.
But factorials
grow exponentially.
So it should be
something like this.
OK.
So we have that
nice approximation.
Does anyone want to work it
out, or will I have to do it?
I'll keep that in mind when
I'm grading your homework.
[LAUGHTER]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So it's log of square root 2
pi n multiplied by n over 2
to the power of n.
I'm going to put
these two together.
So 2 pi n over-- There's
an n over 2 there, right?
So it's n over 2E times n
over 2 to the power of 2.
OK, I can get rid of this
guy, because it's a constant.
I can get-- No, I can't
get rid of this guy yet.
AUDIENCE: In the denominator
shouldn't it be 2pi n over 2
under the radical?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
2pi n over 2, so
this simplifies.
OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Square
at the bottom term,
you can get rid of the
square root on the end--
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --and then cancel
the some of the exponents.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Do you want to come help me?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
VICTOR COSTAN: Thanks so much.
STUDENT: OK.
So we can distribute this
exponent here to cancel this.
And then we get square root
of pi n times n over 2.
And it'd be n-- sorry
about my handwriting.
VICTOR COSTAN: I think
it's better than mine
by quite a bit.
STUDENT: Square root of pi n.
And this is square root
squared, so that cancels .
Times n over E to the n.
AUDIENCE: Do you need
parenthesis around n over 2E?
STUDENT: Yeah.
That's probably good.
So, since this is n over E
to the n, and n over 2E n.
Well since they're
to the n, both the
n we can give them a single
exponent and cancel stuff.
So we just get square root
of pi n to the times 2
the n, over pi n.
Can do some more cancelling
and just get 2 the n over--
Going to simplify this to the
n over the square root of n.
We can take out the pi, because
it's in our natural logarithm.
It's a constant factor.
And this is log of-- and
then-- Since it's a log of,
it's just log of 2 to the n.
So it's-- say since it's log
you can turn it into log of 2
to the n minus log
of square root of n.
Log of 2 to the n is a
much greater complexity
than square root
of n, so we can--
VICTOR COSTAN: Sweet.
Thank you.
So see?
Complicated formula-- Even
more complicated formula
came out to be
one of the numbers
that I promised it
would come out to.
Thanks for the help.
So you can get rid of the
pi as soon as you want to.
And this is the last step.
I just want to
say it again, just
make sure everyone heard it.
So once you get
here, you get this,
order n minus log
of square root of n,
which is-- This is-- This is
order n minus one half log n.
And the log n is
much smaller than n,
so this goes away completely.
And you get this as
your final answer.
OK.
Does this make sense?
Any questions?
Anyone?
How many people are still
paying attention honestly?
Wow.
Nice.
You should come to
all my sections.
OK.
Let's talk about something
we covered in class.
Let's talk about peak finding.
And we'll start with
1D peak finding,
and then we'll go
to 2D peak finding.
So does anyone remember the
pseudocode for the faster 1D
peak finding by any chance?
ID peak finding.
I think everyone said
they went to lecture,
so I don't have to explain
what peak finding is, right?
OK.
So that's go for it.
So suppose I have
a few numbers--
3-- let me write this one--
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 6, 5, 4.
So the peak finding problem says
there's an array of numbers,
and I want to find
the local peak.
And the local peak
is a number that's
surrounded by numbers that
are smaller or equal to it.
So there shouldn't be any
larger numbers than it.
And I want to find a
peak as quickly as I can.
So what's the faster
algorithm that we talked about
in lecture?
Yes?
OK.
You didn't answer, right,
as much, at least so.
AUDIENCE: Binary search?
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
It's exactly like binary search.
Yep.
Do you wanna help me
write the pseudocode?
You can tell me what it is.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So, I guess well
start in the middle.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Start in the middle.
If you-- If you write
this on your Pset
you might want to be a
little bit more formal.
Someone asked about proofs.
I would say
something like, start
by looking at the middle
element of the array.
Same thing though.
OK.
So let's pretend
this is the middle.
Now it is.
What do I do?
AUDIENCE: Then you can check
one side in the middle.
So it's [INAUDIBLE]
the right side.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
I'm looking at the right side.
I see a 7 there,
so I know for sure
that this is not a local peak.
Right?
What do I do now?
AUDIENCE: So now you can
start over, and using 7.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
What if-- This would be small.
What if I would look at 5 first?
Or you should I look
at the other side too?
AUDIENCE: Well you don't have
to in this case, but if you--
But if 7 were smaller
then you would
go and look at the
other side, and check
to see if 5 is also smaller.
In that case you've
already found the peak.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So I have to look at both sides
and make sure-- if none of them
is smaller, than I-- I'm sorry.
If none of them is
bigger, I found the peak.
If any of them is bigger then
I can go whichever way I want.
So I saw my 7, I'm going
to cut this in half.
And now I look at this.
You were saying, right?
So look at the
neighbors-- By the way,
can anyone understand
my handwriting?
Is it even worth
bothering to write?
AUDIENCE: It's pretty good.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
I see three nods.
I'm going to write for
those three people.
AUDIENCE: It's just
we haven't taken
any cursive in about 12 years.
So--
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Thanks.
Not feeling well at all.
OK look at neighbors,
figure out if you're a peak.
You're one of the people
that said you can read it,
so now there's only two people
that can read my handwriting
and that I like.
[LAUGHTER]
VICTOR COSTAN: Look
at the neighbors.
See if local peak.
And if not, figure out
which way to go in.
And I'll say if not recurse.
So what's the running
time for this?
Suppose I have n
elements to start with,
that's my array size.
I will use t of n
as my running time.
So to figure out the running
time for the whole algorithm,
I have to look at the
running time for each step
and add them up.
Right?
What's the running time
for the first step?
Looking in the middle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the middle elements.
VICTOR COSTAN: 1.
1.
I would not say 0.
I still have to look at it.
Or to be on the safe side
you say 1, theta of 1.
It's a constant.
OK.
Now I have to look
at the neighbors,
and I have to see if one
of them is bigger or not.
How about that?
How much time is left?
I heard the constant.
OK.
Very soft voice, but I
heard a constant there,
so I'm going to take it.
So this guy is a constant.
If it's a local,
if you come down.
If it's not a local peak, what's
the running time for this?
n over 2, since--
AUDIENCE: If you FOIL that you
divide by [INAUDIBLE], right?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yep.
So I'm looking at this guy.
It's clearly not a peak.
So I'm going to look
on the right side,
because I see a 7 here
that's bigger than a 6.
So now I have the same problem,
except my array size just
dropped to half.
So same problem, because I
already have a name for it,
except the input
size is different.
So the running time for this
entire step is theta of 1
plus T of n over 2.
So the running time
for the whole thing
is-- I should have said
theta of 1 here, sorry.
So theta of 1 plus theta
of 1 plus T of n over 2.
So this is theta 1
plus T of n over 2.
So I wrote out my
pseudocode, looked
at the running time for
each step, added them up.
Now I have a recurrence,
and I have to solve it.
Let's solve it.
We sort of glossed
over that in lectures,
so we're going to do it now.
So T of n equals theta
of 1 plus T of n over 2.
I'm going to expand this
using the definition.
And theta of one is long, so I'm
going to call this c instead.
It's a constant, right?
So c plus-- expanding
this-- c plus T of n over 4.
I'm going to expand it again.
And again-- Anyone
getting bored of this?
So if I expand it a lot of
times, I'm going to get i times
c, plus T of n
divided by 2 to the n.
And you can expand
it as many times
as you want until
we see the pattern,
but this is the pattern.
So I have a recurrence.
What else do I need in
order to get a function?
I need a base case.
So the problem size gets
smaller and smaller and smaller,
but at some point
it becomes so small
that I can solve it
just by looking at it.
What's that case?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So if I have an array of
one element, it's a peak.
Right?
Job done.
So T of 1 is a constant.
So I want to write this in such
a way that this becomes this.
So I want to figure out
an i such that-- Yeah.
T of n divided by 2 to
the i equals T of 1.
And the easiest way
of doing that is
to say that n divided
by 2 to the i is 1.
So i is the inverse of
an exponential-- Anyone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VICTOR COSTAN:
Logarithm, thank you.
Log n.
So I have i, and I'm going
to plug it back in here.
And I get constant times log
n, plus T of 1, which I know
is theta of 1.
I'm going to make
this theta of 1 again.
So theta of 1 times
log n, plus theta of 1.
And I know that log n
dominates a constant,
so this is going to
be theta of log n.
Solved.
OK.
How are we doing?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the second
to last from the bottom,
I don't understand
[INAUDIBLE] of c times log n
replace i by log n.
In the second part of the
equation, how did you--
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So in the jump from here
to here, where I said
i equals log n-- Right?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So i becomes log n, c stays c.
You're wondering about
this part, right?
So if i is log n,
then 2 to the i is n.
So I have T of 1,
which I have here.
So I want this to
have this happen.
When I'm solving for i here, I
set this guy to my base case,
so that I can get
this to happen.
The idea here is that you're
expanding the recursion
forever, and you know
that at some point
you're going to have to stop.
When do you stop?
You stop at the base case.
So you force this to
become the base case.
OK?
OK.
Let's do 2D peak finding.
Let's talk about
it a little bit.
So 2D peak finding is
exactly like 1D peak finding,
except you have a 2D matrix
instead of a 1D array.
Let's see if I
can do this right.
So suppose this is our matrix.
And suppose these are the rows.
Suppose we have m
rows and n columns.
Can anyone remind me what
the psuedocode for 2D
peak finding that we
talked about in lecture?
So we had two attempts.
The first one was
a clear failure.
It didn't work.
The second one worked.
And we talked about its
running time a little bit.
And then [INAUDIBLE] asked
you to think of a variation
to the second one.
So let's do those
straight up second version
of the pseudocode
without the variation.
So 2D peak finding.
What is the algorithm?
All right.
One person was not asleep in my
section at the end of lecture.
I'm proud.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Well, Which one of us?
We both spoke at the same time.
VICTOR COSTAN: You had
your hand up first though.
AUDIENCE: So you just pick
a middle of the column.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
And then you find
the peak there.
AUDIENCE: And then you shift
the neighbors, I think.
VICTOR COSTAN: Find
peak neighbors.
AUDIENCE: Neighbors
in the same room?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
VICTOR COSTAN: That's the
horizontal line, right?
OK.
So what do you mean
by find the peak here?
AUDIENCE: Like
within the column?
VICTOR COSTAN: Yes.
So find the peak using what
we talked about before?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Find 1D peak.
So you're thinking ahead.
You're thinking of the
variation that [INAUDIBLE]
asked you guys to
think about at home.
I'm glad you thought about it.
That's good.
But what's the one
that we had in lecture?
I don't want to
think about-- I don't
want to give you
guys the answer yet.
So what did we say we were
going to do in lecture?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think we
just picked a spot,
checked the neighbors
and kept walking uphill.
That makes sense.
Every time we found a
neighbor that was bigger,
we moved to that spot.
Checked its neighbors.
VICTOR COSTAN: So
this is the-- This
is the first
algorithm that's slow.
It works.
You're going to get
the correct answer.
But it's slow because if you
have some handily crafted
matrix you can go like
this, and you're basically
going through the whole matrix.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think there's
like an algorithm that's
find a-- look through the
column for its maximum,
and then look to either side.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
So instead of finding
a 1D peak, we're
going to find the maximum value.
OK.
And this is correct, and let's
look at its running time.
Does anyone want to help me?
So this is T of n m.
Right?
Then rows, then columns.
So what's the running
time for the first step?
Come on.
This is the easy one.
Yes?
The constant.
Perfect.
OK.
What's the running
time for finding
a maximum amount of n numbers?
AUDIENCE: n.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Perfect.
And suppose we do that here?
Suppose these rows don't exist.
Suppose this is
my entire matrix.
And I'm here, and I
found the maximum.
What do I do?
I look left, I look right.
If both of them are
smaller, then it
means I found my
peak, because I know
that number was a
maximum in my column.
Now if that's not the case, if
I find a number that's bigger,
I'll go in that direction.
Does that sound reasonable?
OK.
So maximum for my column,
and I'm going to go right.
So check neighbors, and I have
the same two conditions there.
If it's a peak, then I'm happy.
Otherwise recurse.
So what's the running
time if I have to recurse?
How does the new
problem look like?
It's an identical problem.
I still have a matrix,
except-- What changed?
So suppose I got here-- and this
is the middle of my matrix--
and I see that
this guy is bigger,
so I'm going to recurse
to the right side.
What happened to
my problem size?
OK?
AUDIENCE: Sorry I'm not
answering your question,
but shouldn't find x
be theta of m, not n?
Is that [INAUDIBLE]?
VICTOR COSTAN: Let me see.
AUDIENCE: I can't tell
VICTOR COSTAN: You are right.
Thank you for paying attention.
Theta m.
Sweet.
That would have
tripped me up later.
Thanks for saving me.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So what was your question?
Sorry.
VICTOR COSTAN: So the question
is, if I have to recurse--
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
VICTOR COSTAN: --what's
the running time?
So I'm-- If I have to recurse,
I'm in this array that was
originally n by m, and I'm
only going to look at the right
side.
How many these-- how many rows
do I have in the [INAUDIBLE]?
Start to the easy one.
AUDIENCE: m.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
Same as before.
How many columns?
AUDIENCE: n over 2.
VICTOR COSTAN: n over 2.
Sweet.
So there recursion
for this is theta of 1
plus theta of m plus
T of n over 2 and m.
I know that a constant can be
absorbed by this other guy,
so it's theta of m
plus T of n over 2 m.
How would I solve this?
What's the first
thing that we need?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Need to figure
out the base case.
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
Excellent.
Base case.
What's the best-- What
was the base case?
AUDIENCE: T of 1
comma T of n-- m.
Sorry.
VICTOR COSTAN: Nice.
AUDIENCE: Equal to O of m.
VICTOR COSTAN: OK.
Sweet.
So if I only have
one column, then I
can do-- I can find the
maximum and I know for sure
that's going to be a peak.
Job done.
That's my base case.
So I'm going to reduce
the problem size in half,
until I get to a single column.
Then I find the peak
there, and I'm happy.
How would I solve
this recurrence?
It's a one minute
answer, because I
think that's exactly how
much time we have, as a hint.
Come on guys, this
looks familiar.
Yes?
AUDIENCE:Going to be something
like the recurrence over
there--
VICTOR COSTAN: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] of just n.
m never changes, right?
So this is basically
a function of n.
So if m never changes, and I
pretend that it's a constant,
this looks exactly like the
recursion-- the recurrence
that we solve before.
T of n is a constant,
plus T of n over 2.
So I'm going to
get that constant,
multiply it by log n, which is
the solution that I had before.
So the running time
is theta of m log n.
All right.
I think I have 30 seconds, so
what if I would choose-- What
if I would try to do
this algorithm instead?
It's another one
minute question.
So I guess I'm cheating.
I'm taking time away.
Sorry.
So what if I would
be finding a 1D
peak instead of
finding a maximum?
I'm looking at the running time,
because if the running time is
going to be the same,
it's not even worth
thinking if it's correct or not.
If it's a more
complicated algorithm
with the same running
time, why care about it?
So is the running time
going to be better?
OK.
I heard a nod.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Won't it
be log m times log n?
VICTOR COSTAN: All right.
So 1D peak is exactly
what we have there.
Thank you.
1D peak is exactly
like you said, log m.
So this constant here
becomes this constant here,
so the algorithm
would be a lot faster.
As an order of magnitude idea,
if your m and n are one million
each, then log n is 20.
So that's a 50 time
max improvement.
And these are real input
sizes you might get.
And that's it.
Thank you guys.